you can learn to kind of watch yourself  like you're watching a stranger  but you have to adopt a position it's a  position of radical humility i would say  both both humility and two senses  so one sense would be the humility of  recognizing your ignorance so you have  to understand that you don't know who  you are  and that's not easy to understand  because you think you know but then you  know  you remember you can't control yourself  very well you're not very disciplined  you're full of flaws maybe you don't  know yourself as well as you think  but it's hard to get low enough  to understand how deeply  it is the case that you are ignorant  about who you are  now there's an upside to that too which  also is that you're also ignorant about  who you could be  and so the discovery of that you know is  some reward for the horror of  determining  who you actually are